Jake: 今天是谷雨
Jake: Today is Gu Yu.
Shure:  今天还是个节气呢
Shure: Today is a solar term.
Lucia: 这是一个节气
Lucia: It's a solar term.
Shure:  是个节气吃什么
Shure: What do you eat during this solar term?
Shure:  吃饺子吧
Shure: Let's eat dumplings.
Lucia: 遇事不决吃饺子
Lucia: When in doubt, eat dumplings.
Shure:  对啊反正咱也不知道吃什么
Shure: Yeah, since we don't know what to eat anyway.
Jake: 摘谷雨茶走
Jake: Let's pick some Gu Yu tea.
Jake: 谷雨祭海
Jake: Gu Yu sea sacrifice.
Jake: 吃春赏花
Jake: Eat spring, enjoy flowers.
Jake: 什么玩意
Jake: What the heck?
Lucia: 不知道在赏花
Lucia: No idea, just enjoying flowers.
Lucia: 咱可以有
Lucia: We could have...
Shure:  那就吃饺子吧
Shure: Let's just eat dumplings.
Jake: 吃饺子行
Jake: Dumplings work.
Jake: 可以啊中午吃饺子吧
Jake: Sure, let's have dumplings for lunch.
Jake: 要不行
Jake: Unless you can't...
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sounds good.
Jake: 妙啊
Jake: Great.
Lucia: 遇事不决吃饺子
Lucia: When in doubt, eat dumplings.
Lucia: 咱这有铅笔吗
Lucia: Do we have any pencils?
Jake: 没有铅笔哦
Jake: No pencils here.
Lucia: 因为这个
Lucia: Because this...
Shure:  昨天昨天晚上怎么偷偷发红包呢
Shure: Why did you secretly send red envelopes last night?
Jake: 那就发工资
Jake: Well, it was payday.
Jake: 哎工资还没发完呢
Jake: Oh wait, we haven't finished paying yet.
Lucia: 突然来真的
Lucia: Suddenly serious.
Lucia: 哈哈哈对
Lucia: Haha, right.
Shure:  哈哈哈对突然变成抢的了
Shure: Hahaha, yeah, it suddenly turned into a robbery.
Shure:  我靠哈哈哈
Shure: Damn, hahaha.
Shure:  昨天晚上睡亏了
Shure: I didn't get enough sleep last night.
Shure:  睡没100块钱哈哈哈
Shure: I lost a hundred bucks worth of sleep, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  卧槽这觉睡的
Shure: Damn, that sleep.
Shure:  我从来没感觉我自己一宿这么值钱过
Shure: I've never felt my sleep was worth so much.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  慢慢
Shure: Slowly.
Shure:  记得那一首歌
Shure: Remember that one song?
Jake: 那个金币是买的对吧
Jake: That gold coin was bought, right?
Jake: 嗯嗯金币就是买的贴纸
Jake: Yeah, the gold coin is just a sticker.
Lucia: 买贴纸今天到了
Lucia: Bought a sticker, it arrived today.
Jake: 那我到了OK哦
Jake: So it arrived, okay.
Shure:  一说到贴纸
Shure: Speaking of stickers.
Jake: 就是贴纸OK
Jake: It's just stickers, okay.
Shure:  我还有点伴手礼
Shure: I also have some gifts.
Jake: 伴手礼
Jake: Gifts?
Jake: 当伴郎去了
Jake: You went to be a groomsman.
Shure:  什么哈哈
Shure: What? Haha.
Shure:  什么烂梗啊
Shure: What kind of joke is that?
Jake: 不是啊伴手礼不是这玩意吗
Jake: No, aren’t gifts these things?
Katrina:  啥呀
Katrina: What?
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Shure:  这是我们乐队LOGO的贴纸
Shure: These are stickers with our band's logo.
Shure:  哇周边产品
Shure: Wow, merch products.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Katrina:  你们好正啊
Katrina: You guys are so proper.
Lucia: 啊你们这个贴纸好客气啊
Lucia: Wow, your stickers are so thoughtful.
Shure:  是的这LOGO花3,000块钱设计的
Shure: Yeah, this logo design cost 3,000 bucks.
Jake: 为什么不送我啊
Jake: Why didn’t you give me one?
Lucia: 好看的好看的
Lucia: They look great, they look great.
Shure:  送的送的都送了
Shure: Everyone got one, they all got one.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What’s this?
Jake: 叫什么呀
Jake: What’s it called?
Shure:  百鸟辞典
Shure: "Dictionary of Birds."
Shure:  这个大概也符合这个元素我感觉
Shure: I think it kind of fits the theme.
Jake: 百鸟辞典
Jake: "Dictionary of Birds."
Jake: 为什么呀
Jake: Why?
Jake: 他怎么3
Jake: How did it...
Jake: 这这3,000块钱给你什么解释的吗
Jake: So, do you have any explanation for this 3,000 bucks?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  没有我感觉让GPT生生也差不多
Shure: No, I feel like GPT would be about the same.
Jake: 不是他他为什么
Jake: No, why did he...
Jake: 你给我讲讲呗
Jake: Can you explain it to me?
Jake: 这为什么长这样啊
Jake: Why does it look like this?
Shure:  就是哎呀
Shure: It's just, well...
Shure:  我我也不会讲
Shure: I can't explain it either.
Jake: 哈哈哈他也没给你讲是吧
Jake: Hahaha, he didn't explain it to you either, right?
Shure:  对我这东西真的只可意会不可言传
Shure: Exactly, this stuff really can only be understood, not explained.
Shure:  看反了看反了
Shure: You got it backwards, you got it backwards.
Lucia: 轩我查了一下
Lucia: Xuan, I checked it out.
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: So,
Lucia: 如果这个花就是有这个花屁股的话
Lucia: if this flower has a bottom like that,
Lucia: 对不起戳到了
Lucia: Sorry, I pointed it out.
Lucia: 就是花瓣的那个压力就不够
Lucia: The pressure on the petals isn't enough.
Lucia: 因为他这个
Lucia: Because this...
Lucia: 我就会把那个压的东西拖起来一点
Lucia: I'd lift the thing pressing it a bit.
Lucia: 嗯所以就花瓣就会变皱
Lucia: So, the petals would wrinkle.
Jake: 那我觉得GPT应该能给你画出来
Jake: I think GPT could draw it for you.
Lucia: 他说可以垫一个厚纸巾或者之类的
Lucia: He said you could put a thick tissue or something under it.
Katrina:  在什么翘屁股的花下面垫一张厚纸巾
Katrina: Put a thick tissue under the flower with a lifted bottom.
Katrina:  因为花朵有一定厚度
Katrina: Because the flower has some thickness.
Lucia: 可能就是施加到花瓣上的压力不够
Lucia: Maybe the pressure on the petals isn't enough.
Lucia: 所以它就水
Lucia: So, it just...
Lucia: 就是一脱水它自己就慢慢缩起来了
Lucia: When it dehydrates, it shrinks up on its own.
Katrina:  单独在他这下面再垫个东西
Katrina: Put something else under it alone.
Lucia: 对就让它跟中间的这个厚度一样
Lucia: Yeah, make it the same thickness as the middle.
Lucia: 或者就像你说的把花瓣撕下来
Lucia: Or like you said, tear off the petals.
Lucia: 然后但是那样的话
Lucia: But if we do that,
Lucia: 我们是不是到时候要给它自己粘起来
Lucia: we would have to stick them back together ourselves.
Katrina:  那样的话就得自己拼成一个花的形状
Katrina: If we do that, we have to piece it into a flower shape ourselves.
Lucia: 好麻烦啊哈哈
Lucia: That's so troublesome, haha.
Katrina:  对啊我看他们
Katrina: Yeah, I saw them...
Katrina:  怎么就直接能压成一个花瓣的样子
Katrina: How do they press it directly into a petal shape?
Katrina:  他们人呢其他的
Katrina: Where are the others?
Lucia: 呃可欣刚才在外面
Lucia: Uh, Kexin was outside just now.
Lucia: 对然后薇薇我也不知道
Lucia: Yeah, and I don't know about Weiwei.
Lucia: 在楼上吗
Lucia: Is she upstairs?
Jake: 我问问我看看去
Jake: I'll ask around and check.
Lucia: 好香啊这个咖啡
Lucia: This coffee smells so good.
Lucia: 偷偷喝一口算了哈哈哈
Lucia: I'll just sneak a sip, hahaha.
Lucia: 哎是你的吗这个咖啡
Lucia: Hey, is this your coffee?
Katrina:  是我的你喝吧
Katrina: It's mine, go ahead and drink it.
Lucia: 啊那我稍微倒一点出来可以吗因为
Lucia: Ah, can I just pour a little bit out because...
Katrina:  可以哎那边有那个热水应该还烫一会
Katrina: Sure, there's hot water over there, it should stay warm for a while.
Katrina:  你给自己泡一下
Katrina: You can make some for yourself.
Lucia: 啊因为我泡一整杯可能喝不完
Lucia: Ah, because if I make a full cup, I might not finish it.
Lucia: 只要一小口谢谢
Lucia: Just a small sip, thanks.
Lucia: 嗯太好了
Lucia: Mmm, perfect.
Lucia: 没有溢出
Lucia: Didn't spill.
Katrina:  放歌DJ
Katrina: Play some music, DJ.
Shure:  是无话可说
Shure: No words to say.
Katrina:  我现在可是正能量博主
Katrina: I'm a positive energy influencer now.
Katrina:  哎呦头疼
Katrina: Oh, my head hurts.
Katrina:  主要买这个花都比较大
Katrina: Mainly, the flowers we bought are quite big.
Lucia: 咱的那个剪刀又上哪去了
Lucia: Where did our scissors go again?
Lucia: 昨天
Lucia: Yesterday...
Shure:  咱们东西
Shure: Our stuff...
Katrina:  还用点中饭我感觉好饱
Katrina: After lunch, I feel so full.
Lucia: 今天一会吧
Lucia: Maybe later today.
Lucia: 刚是说什么
Lucia: What were we just saying?
Lucia: 吃饺子哈哈哈对
Lucia: Eating dumplings, hahaha, right.
Shure:  今天是个节气
Shure: Today is a solar term.
Shure:  所以不知道吃什么就吃点饺子吧
Shure: So, when in doubt, just have some dumplings.
Lucia: 哎哈喽
Lucia: Hey, hello.
Alice: 他们去哪了呀
Alice: Where did they go?
Lucia: 他们还在这
Lucia: They're still here.
Lucia: 还在还在房子里
Lucia: They're still in the house.
Lucia: 你指哪个
Lucia: Which one are you asking about?
Lucia: 去哪了女生
Lucia: Where did the girls go?
Alice: 女生
Alice: The girls.
Lucia: 哦女生
Lucia: Oh, the girls.
Lucia: 呃雨轩在一楼
Lucia: Uh, Yuxuan is on the first floor.
Lucia: 然后薇薇可能在二楼
Lucia: And Weiwei might be on the second floor.
Lucia: 因为我没看到他
Lucia: Because I haven't seen her.
Lucia: 你坐这吗
Lucia: Are you sitting here?
Lucia: 嗯也行
Lucia: Hmm, that's fine.
Lucia: 我其实是想找剪刀但是不知道在哪
Lucia: Actually, I was looking for the scissors but I don't know where they are.
Alice: 剪刀没有在工具那吗
Alice: Aren't the scissors with the tools?
Lucia: 好像没有咱的剪刀总是
Lucia: It seems like we don't always have our scissors.
Lucia: 可能因为咱们剪刀太少了
Lucia: Maybe because we have too few scissors.
Alice: 你把门关上
Alice: Close the door.
Alice: 虫子会进去
Alice: Bugs will get in.
Alice: 露西
Alice: Lucia.
Lucia: 我真的觉得你这个耳机套好好看
Lucia: I really think your headphone cover is so pretty.
Alice: 呵呵可爱
Alice: Haha, cute.
Alice: 你要链接吗
Alice: Do you want the link?
Lucia: 哎可以可以我回去给你找吧
Lucia: Oh, sure, I can go back and find it for you.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Alright.
Alice: 因为他比较早了
Alice: Because it's been around for a while.
Alice: 可爱看这10块钱啊
Alice: It's cute and only costs 10 bucks.
Lucia: 哎那还挺划算的
Lucia: Oh, that's pretty affordable.
Jake: 我问他故意吃
Jake: I asked him to eat on purpose.
Alice: 我很会买小东西
Alice: I'm good at buying little things.
Alice: 嗯你有特别好的朋友吗
Alice: Hmm, do you have really close friends?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 哎呦嘶不同阶段各有一些
Lucia: Well, at different stages, I've had different ones.
Lucia: 因为我一直在不断的变换地方
Lucia: Because I've been constantly moving places.
Lucia: 所以就有的时候
Lucia: So sometimes,
Lucia: 可能大家不在同一个地方的话
Lucia: if we're not in the same place,
Lucia: 各自有事情好吗
Lucia: everyone has their own things to do.
Alice:那你有
Alice: Do you have...
Alice: 这个如果说你最好的朋友的话
Alice: If you had to say your best friends,
Alice: 你会想到几个
Alice: how many would you think of?
Lucia: 呃大概三四个
Lucia: Uh, probably three or four.
Lucia: 因为醉嘛就
Lucia: Because best friends...
Lucia: 对就可能联联系时间要比较长一点
Lucia: yeah, we might need to stay in touch for a longer time.
Lucia: 联系要比较紧密一点
Lucia: Stay in close contact.
Lucia: 我感觉吧虽然说普通的小伙伴很多
Lucia: I feel that while I have many ordinary friends,
Alice: 但是比较喜欢交朋友
Alice: But you like making friends more.
Lucia: 哎我觉得我会比较喜欢啊
Lucia: Yeah, I think I like it more.
Lucia: 但是这个事情就比较随机
Lucia: But it can be quite random.
Lucia: 因为可能并不是所有的人
Lucia: Because not everyone
Lucia: 跟你兴趣爱好啊
Lucia: shares your interests,
Lucia: 或者话题啊或者之类的
Lucia: or topics, or whatever.
Lucia: 或者生活习惯都特别相近
Lucia: Or living habits are very similar.
Lucia: 所以就是
Lucia: So,
Lucia: 如果说整体来说大家还可以友好
Lucia: overall, as long as we can get along friendly and happily,
Lucia: 可友好快乐的相处的话
Lucia: it's good enough.
Lucia: 就可以当小伙伴
Lucia: Then we can be buddies.
Lucia: 然后如果说某一点上
Lucia: And if at some point,
Lucia: 就是大家兴趣特别相似
Lucia: we find our interests are very similar,
Lucia: 那可能就
Lucia: then maybe
Lucia: 就是关系会更亲密之类这种
Lucia: the relationship could become closer.
Lucia: 但这个就比较随机
Lucia: But that's quite random,
Lucia: 因为你在跟别人接触之前
Lucia: because before you interact with someone,
Lucia: 你也不可能说
Lucia: you can't really say,
Lucia: 我看一眼
Lucia: just by looking,
Lucia: 我就判断出来这个人就我多喜欢他呀
Lucia: that you know how much you'll like them.
Lucia: 或者说大家相处多融洽之类
Lucia: Or how well you'll get along.
Alice: 朋友确实分等级的
Alice: Friends do come in different levels.
Alice:今日谷雨
Alice: Today is Grain Rain.
Alice: 春天的最后一个节气
Alice: The last solar term of spring.
Alice:谷雨
Alice: Grain Rain.
Alice:赏牡丹吃春菜
Alice: Appreciating peonies and eating spring vegetables.
Lucia: 学硕说一会可以吃饺子
Lucia: Shure said we can have dumplings later.
Lucia: 因为今天是一个节气
Lucia: Because today is a solar term,
Lucia: 所以遇事不决
Lucia: so when in doubt,
Lucia: 吃饺子
Lucia: eat dumplings.
Lucia: 你们点那个还是我们自己包吧
Lucia: Should we order them or make them ourselves?
Lucia: 啊应该是点吧
Lucia: Ah, we should order.
Lucia: 点外卖吧
Lucia: Order delivery.
Lucia: 自己包饺子
Lucia: Making dumplings ourselves
Lucia: 这会应该来不及了
Lucia: would take too long now.
Lucia: what's this
Lucia: What's this?
Lucia: 这什么夹核桃的葡萄
Lucia: What's this grape with a walnut cracker?
Alice: 不知道是不是开酒瓶子还是啥的
Alice: Not sure if it's for opening wine bottles or what.
Lucia: 开瓶器
Lucia: A bottle opener.
Lucia: 不知道今天干什么
Lucia: Not sure what to do today.
Alice: 这第几天来着
Alice: What day is it today?
Lucia: 十九号
Lucia: The nineteenth.
Alice:三四我们这第四天吧
Alice: So this is our fourth day, right?
Lucia: 嗯二三对
Lucia: Yeah, twenty-three, right.
Lucia: 十五号如果也算半天的话就是第4.5天
Lucia: If we count the fifteenth as half a day, it's 4.5 days.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 15天不算
Alice: The fifteenth doesn't count.
Alice: 6789
Alice: Six, seven, eight, nine.
Lucia: 对那就是4天
Lucia: Right, so it's four days.
Alice: 你喜欢吃春菜吗
Alice: Do you like eating spring vegetables?
Lucia: 没吃过呃
Lucia: I've never eaten it, uh
Alice: 呃就是一类菜
Alice: Uh, it's just a type of dish
Alice: 就春天新鲜的那种野菜
Alice: It's like fresh wild vegetables in spring
Alice: 那种新鲜的野菜
Alice: That kind of fresh wild vegetables
Alice: 或者那种树上长得
Alice: Or the ones that grow on trees
Lucia: for example鱼签算吗
Lucia: For example, does fish skewers count?
Lucia: 算啊
Lucia: Yeah, it counts
Lucia: 还好我们家可能不很经常收集这些
Lucia: Luckily, our family doesn't collect these often
Lucia: 啊香椿
Lucia: Ah, toon shoots
Alice: 香椿
Alice: Toon shoots
Lucia: 我喜欢
Lucia: I like them
Alice:香椿炒鸡蛋
Alice: Toon shoots with scrambled eggs
Alice: 好想去挖野菜呀
Alice: I really want to go dig wild vegetables
Lucia: 那我们申请一下
Lucia: Then let's apply
Lucia: 附近有没有啥地方可以去挖
Lucia: See if there's any place nearby where we can dig
Alice: 但我不太认识
Alice: But I don't really know
Lucia: 我也不太认识墓穴还有
Lucia: Me neither, and also the graves
Alice: 觉得挖野菜很好玩
Alice: I think digging wild vegetables is fun
Alice: 现在有点晚了
Alice: It's a bit late now
Alice: 4月初差不多清明那段
Alice: Early April, around Qingming Festival
Alice: 可适合挖野菜了
Alice: It's perfect for digging wild vegetables
Lucia: 他们里面开始KTV了
Lucia: They're starting karaoke inside
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah
Lucia: 我又好像听见他们开始KTV了
Lucia: I think I hear them starting karaoke again
Alice: 我觉得我就很适合过这种很安静的
Alice: I feel like I'm suited for this kind of quiet life
Alice: 自己有个小院子的生活
Alice: Having a little yard of my own
Lucia: 我也想自己有个小院子
Lucia: I also want a little yard of my own
Lucia: 但是我不喜欢底下都是石子
Lucia: But I don't like having gravel on the ground
Lucia: 我要把它弄成两边花坛
Lucia: I want to make flower beds on both sides
Alice: 好想在农村有一个小院
Alice: I really want a small yard in the countryside
Lucia: 我也想哈哈
Lucia: Me too, haha
Alice:这个我想就可以办到
Alice: I think it can be done
Lucia: （歌词）think of me think of me how sleep
Lucia: (singing) think of me, think of me how sleep
Lucia: 哎可是为什么你的耳机不在里面呢
Lucia: Hey, but why aren't your headphones in?
Alice: 我拿出来
Alice: I took them out
Alice: 你说刚刚吗
Alice: You mean just now?
Lucia: 对哦咦哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, oh haha
Alice:刚刚带着
Alice: I was wearing them
Alice: 我刚刚戴着然后你过来我就把它取掉了
Alice: I was wearing them and then you came over so I took them off
Lucia: 好困想睡觉了
Lucia: I'm so sleepy, I want to go to bed
Alice: 昨天几点睡的啊
Alice: What time did you go to bed last night?
Lucia: 啊挺晚的
Lucia: Oh, pretty late.
Lucia: 我可能2点多
Lucia: Maybe around 2 AM.
Alice: 嗯我也差不多快三点吧
Alice: Yeah, I was almost 3 AM.
Lucia: 对我也
Lucia: Same here.
Lucia: 因为昨天晚上我刚刚还有个邮件要回
Lucia: I had an email to reply to last night.
Lucia: 然后又在那里折腾了一会
Lucia: Then I was just messing around for a bit.
Lucia: 哦天呐
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia: 说到这个
Lucia: Speaking of that,
Lucia: 我还有一些东西要搞
Lucia: I still have some stuff to do.
Lucia: 算了不想戴着眼镜搞
Lucia: Never mind, I don't want to do it with my glasses on.
Lucia: 等他休息的时候再弄一弄真麻烦
Lucia: I'll do it when he's resting, it's such a hassle.
Lucia: 他们好嗨
Lucia: They're having so much fun.
Lucia: 我去看看有没有什么可以策划的活动
Lucia: I'll check if there are any activities we can plan.
Lucia: 我在想去把我的那个小桌子支起来
Lucia: I'm thinking of setting up my little table.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 他其实是一个小的床头柜
Lucia: It's actually a small bedside table.
Lucia: 我觉得可能应该没有这个高
Lucia: I don't think it's this tall.
Lucia: 估计有这么高吧
Lucia: Maybe it's about this tall.
Alice: 我的快递应该都在明天吧
Alice: My packages should arrive tomorrow.
Lucia: 我希望我
Lucia: I hope my
Lucia: 我希望我在淘宝上买那些明天能到
Lucia: I hope the stuff I bought on Taobao arrives tomorrow.
Lucia: 我本来想多在淘宝上买的
Lucia: I wanted to buy more from Taobao.
Lucia: 但是因为感觉有的可能就是他
Lucia: But I was worried some items might not arrive.
Lucia: 怕他到不了
Lucia: So I found stuff on JD.
Lucia: 然后就是京东上能找到的
Lucia: I bought some things from JD.
Lucia: 我就在京东上买了
Lucia: But for small decorations,
Lucia: 但是那种小东西就小装饰
Lucia: JD doesn't have many of them.
Lucia: 京东上很多就没有
Lucia: And if they do, they're really expensive.
Lucia: 而且或者有的话就特别贵
Lucia: Or if they have them, they're super expensive.
Alice: 反正这几个软件就是这个优劣吧
Alice: Yeah, each platform has its pros and cons.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 所以几件那个稍微大一点的东西
Lucia: So for a few slightly bigger items,
Lucia: 我在京东上买了
Lucia: I bought them on JD.
Lucia: 因为大一点的
Lucia: Because for the bigger stuff,
Lucia: 比如说我的那个
Lucia: Like my
Lucia: 我的那个照片墙
Lucia: My photo wall.
Lucia: 我现在发现我的照片墙买的有点小
Lucia: I now realize my photo wall is a bit small.
Lucia: 因为就是我本来是想买个大一点的
Lucia: I originally wanted to buy a bigger one.
Lucia: 然后但是大一点的
Lucia: But the bigger ones...
Lucia: 我就想他那个就是会不会太大了
Lucia: I just thought that might be too big.
Lucia: 因为我其实没有量
Lucia: Because I actually didn't measure.
Lucia: 我那个房子具体的长宽
Lucia: The exact length and width of my room.
Lucia: 我就买了一个小的
Lucia: So I bought a smaller one.
Lucia: 但是小的到了之后
Lucia: But when the small one arrived,
Lucia: 我发现好像有那么一点点小
Lucia: I found it was a bit too small.
Lucia: 希望有那个渔网给它装饰一下之后
Lucia: I hope decorating it with a fishing net
Lucia: 能显得不那么空
Lucia: will make it look less empty.
Lucia: 因为只挂一个小的看起来还挺空的
Lucia: Because just hanging the small one looks quite empty.
Lucia: 然后我照片墙和小柜子在京东上买的
Lucia: And I bought the photo wall and the small cabinet on JD.
Lucia: 还买了一个小夜灯
Lucia: I also bought a small night light.
Alice: 嗯本来想买一个氛围灯
Alice: Hmm, I originally wanted to buy an ambient light.
Alice: 后来发现氛围灯都是那种主播啊
Alice: But then I found out those are usually used by streamers.
Alice: 什么的用的
Alice: Or something like that.
Alice: 就没有我想要的灯光颜色
Alice: They didn't have the color I wanted.
Lucia: 哦对我本来也是
Lucia: Oh right, I thought so too.
Lucia: 我本来不是想买个那种
Lucia: I originally wanted to buy one of those
Lucia: 可以水波纹的那样的灯
Lucia: with a water ripple effect.
Lucia: 然后但是那种水波纹灯我觉得就是
Lucia: But I thought the water ripple lights
Lucia: 好像它效果都不是那么好看
Lucia: didn't look that good.
Lucia: 如果好看的话就特别贵
Lucia: If they looked good, they were super expensive.
Lucia: 就大概得一二百那种
Lucia: Like around 100 or 200 bucks.
Lucia: 然后我觉得
Lucia: So I thought,
Lucia: 哎呀这个这个小灯好像不必要那么贵
Lucia: Oh man, this little light doesn't need to be that expensive.
Lucia: 然后我最后就换了一个小夜灯
Lucia: So in the end I switched to a small night light.
Lucia: 但那个夜灯因为是在京东上
Lucia: But because I got it from JD,
Lucia: 所以没有淘宝上便宜
Lucia: it wasn't as cheap as on Taobao.
Lucia: 就小东西哎还是在淘宝上买更合适
Lucia: For small things, Taobao is more suitable.
Alice: 我有几个在拼多多上买的
Alice: I bought a few things on Pinduoduo.
Alice: 拼多多也很适合买那种小小的东西
Alice: Pinduoduo is also good for buying small stuff.
Lucia: 有道理拼多多的话他
Lucia: Makes sense, does Pinduoduo
Lucia: 他能就是比较快的送到吗
Lucia: deliver quickly?
Alice: 不一定就跟淘宝里差不多
Alice: Not necessarily, it's about the same as Taobao.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 他不像京东上有自己的物流
Lucia: It's not like JD with its own logistics.
Jake: 我没在拼多多上买过
Jake: I've never bought anything on Pinduoduo.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 来来吧
Jake: Come on.
Lucia: 呃什么
Lucia: Uh, what?
Jake: 每天都要
Jake: Every day, you have to...
Lucia: 呃我来吧
Lucia: Uh, I'll do it.
Lucia: 呃放到放到放到
Lucia: Uh, put it, put it, put it.
Jake: 放到放到要不就放
Jake: Put it, put it, or just put it.
Jake: 哎就放放客厅吧
Jake: Hey, just put it in the living room.
Lucia: 其实放外面也行
Lucia: Actually, putting it outside is fine too.
Jake: 也行放客厅放客厅放客厅
Jake: That works too, put it in the living room, put it in the living room.
Lucia: 哈哈可以可以
Lucia: Haha, that's fine.
Jake: 拍拍得了
Jake: Just take a picture and be done.
Jake: 要不放二楼去
Jake: Or put it on the second floor.
Jake: 放二楼拆吧
Jake: Put it on the second floor and unpack it.
Jake: 位置大一点放二楼桌上拆吧
Jake: There's more space, unpack it on the second floor table.
Lucia: 也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 一楼用的东西在一楼拆
Lucia: Things used on the first floor, unpack on the first floor.
Lucia: 二楼用的东西在二楼拆
Lucia: Things used on the second floor, unpack on the second floor.
Lucia: 要不然话都搬上去然后再搬下来对吧
Lucia: Otherwise, we'd have to move everything up and then back down, right?
Lucia: 大家可以认领一下自己的快递
Lucia: Everyone can claim their own parcels.
Lucia: 不过我今天应该就一个
Lucia: But I think I only have one today.
Lucia: 剩下都得明天才能到
Lucia: The rest will arrive tomorrow.
Lucia: 我想给你看那个小夜灯
Lucia: I want to show you this little night light.
Lucia: 他真的很可爱
Lucia: It's really cute.
Lucia: 是我特别喜欢玩的一个
Lucia: It's one of my favorite things to play with.
Lucia: 以前特别喜欢玩的一个小游戏
Lucia: It used to be one of my favorite mini-games.
Lucia: 里面的那种这个
Lucia: The kind that was inside this.
Lucia: 看有没有很可爱
Lucia: Look, isn't it cute?
Lucia: 就是纪念碑谷
Lucia: It's from Monument Valley.
Alice: 嗯好可爱
Alice: Hmm, so cute.
Alice:就是那个什么小人就通关那个小人
Alice: It's like the little character you guide through the levels.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 我觉得他这个设计还蛮好看的
Lucia: I think the design is pretty nice.
Lucia: 希望他到了好看不好看我就退货
Lucia: If it looks good when it arrives, great. If not, I'll return it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不好看退货
Lucia: Hahaha, if it doesn't look good, I'll return it.
Lucia: 嗯怎么了
Lucia: Uh, what's up?
Shure:  我以为你还有这手艺呢哈哈哈
Shure: I thought you had this skill, haha.
Lucia: 这个可能是杨老师买的
Lucia: This might have been bought by Mr. Yang.
Shure:  原来我私人iPad从来不会给我推
Shure: My personal iPad never pushes this stuff to me.
Shure:  这种华语大流行你知道吗
Shure: You know, this kind of popular Chinese stuff.
Lucia: 这个应该也是
Lucia: This might be the same.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina:  哦你的哦
Katrina: Oh, is this yours?
Katrina:  把这个拆了吧
Katrina: Let's unpack this one.
Lucia: 卖贴纸的小女孩
Lucia: The girl selling stickers
Lucia: i dont really understand
Lucia: I don't really understand
Alice: 剪刀嘞
Alice: Scissors, where are they?
Lucia: 每个人都在讲剪刀
Lucia: Everyone is talking about scissors
Alice: 也没有小刀呀
Alice: There's no small knife either
Alice: 我的快递呢
Alice: Where's my package?
Alice: 就这些吗
Alice: Is this all?
Alice: 不对啊
Alice: No, wait
Lucia: 有的可能
Lucia: Maybe
Lucia: 是不是还没到
Lucia: Hasn't it arrived yet?
Alice: 我的到了呀他没有帮我拿呀
Alice: Mine has arrived, but he didn't bring it to me
Jake: 那你就在群里面干他
Jake: Then just call him out in the group
Lucia: battle一下
Lucia: Start a battle
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 你们会说家乡话吗
Jake: Can you speak your hometown dialect?
Lucia: 会但是北方话
Lucia: Yes, but it's Northern dialect
Lucia: 其实就是普通话基础上变个调
Lucia: Actually, it's just a variation of Mandarin
Jake: 变调是确实是
Jake: Yeah, it's really just a variation
Lucia: 你们那边那应该也是
Lucia: It's probably the same for you guys too
Lucia: 你们那边应该也是
Alice: 没有啊
Alice: No, not really
Alice: 我的调很准
Alice: My tone is pretty accurate
Alice: 但是如果说就是专有的一些
Alice: But if you're talking about specific terms
Alice: 那啥
Alice: Like
Alice: 就是
Alice: Just
Alice: 我能听出来谁是郑州的谁不是郑州的
Alice: I can tell who's from Zhengzhou and who's not
Alice: 就是那种河南话
Alice: Like Henan dialect
Alice: 不是也分区的吗
Alice: Isn't it also divided by regions?
Lucia: 哦哎那已经很厉害了我根本
Lucia: Oh wow, that's really impressive. I can't
Alice: 这个很难界定吧
Alice: It's hard to define, right?
Alice: 是一个连续统
Alice: It's a continuum
Lucia: 我根本听不出来
Lucia: I can't tell at all
Jake: 那陕西会分吗
Jake: Does Shaanxi have distinctions?
Lucia: 会粉但我我其实听不出来因为
Lucia: Yes, but I actually can't tell because
Jake: 西安和比如说汉中
Jake: Like Xi'an and for example, Hanzhong
Lucia: 对会有区别
Lucia: Yeah, there's a difference
Lucia: 像我那个
Lucia: Like
Lucia: 我有我有
Lucia: I have, I have
Lucia: 我有舍友然后他们也是陕西人
Lucia: I have roommates, and they are also from Shaanxi
Lucia: 然后我给他们说就
Lucia: And I tell them about it
Lucia: 我们
Lucia: We
Lucia: 因为我们家就是说普通话比较多
Lucia: Because in our family, we mostly speak Mandarin.
Lucia: 然后就只有我姥姥姥爷他们说那个
Lucia: And only my grandma and grandpa speak that
Lucia: 陕陕西话
Lucia: Shaanxi dialect.
Lucia: 而且他们应该是因为上年纪了
Lucia: And I think it's because they're getting older
Lucia: 才开始说普通话
Lucia: that they started speaking Mandarin.
Lucia: 所以口音改不过来
Lucia: So their accent couldn't change.
Lucia: 所以就是那种陕普
Lucia: So it's kind of like a mix of Shaanxi and Mandarin.
Lucia: 而不是纯正的陕西话
Lucia: It's not pure Shaanxi dialect.
Alice: 洪掌柜就是陕西的
Alice: Manager Hong is from Shaanxi.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So
Lucia: 对所以就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, so it's like
Lucia: 那
Lucia: that
Lucia: 有就是我给他们说的时候我舍友就说
Lucia: When I speak to them, my roommate says
Lucia: 啊说你说的是西安话
Lucia: Oh, you're speaking Xi'an dialect.
Lucia: 但是就是你让我去听
Lucia: But if you ask me to listen
Lucia: 不同地区的话的话我听不出来
Lucia: to different regional dialects, I can't tell the difference.
Lucia: 我觉得都一样的会有一点点区别
Lucia: I think they all sound the same with a little bit of difference.
Jake: 西安和陕北会有大的差别吗
Jake: Is there a big difference between Xi'an and northern Shaanxi?
Lucia: 哦好像陕北口音会差别大一点
Lucia: Oh, it seems like the northern Shaanxi accent is more different.
Lucia: 就是陕北会
Lucia: Like northern Shaanxi
Lucia: 我怎么形容呢形容不出来但是对会
Lucia: How do I describe it? I can't really describe it, but yeah, it is.
Lucia: 那个差别呢就是可能能听出来一点
Lucia: The difference is probably noticeable to some extent.
Alice: 我的神呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Lucia: 但是其他的就听不太出来
Lucia: But for other regions, I can't really tell.
Lucia: 我会觉得都一样
Lucia: I feel like they all sound the same.
Tasha: 能帮我一下吗
Tasha: Can you help me out?
Tasha: 拿到外面晒一下
Tasha: Take it outside to dry.
Tasha: 我感觉有点味道哦
Tasha: I feel like it has a bit of a smell.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Sure.
Jake: 这就是我们要摆甜品的东西嗯
Jake: This is the stuff we need to set up the desserts, right?
Alice: 是有点味道吧
Alice: It does smell a bit, right?
Jake: 今天没太阳
Jake: There's no sun today.
Lucia: 嗯有一点点
Lucia: Yeah, a little bit.
Lucia: 可能是气味
Lucia: Maybe it's the smell.
Jake: 我午饭已经买好了
Jake: I've already bought lunch.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake: 买了
Jake: I bought it.
Lucia: 饺子吗
Lucia: Dumplings?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 还有那个香椿饼
Jake: And also that Chinese toon pancake.
Alice: 谁香椿饼
Alice: Who made Chinese toon pancake?
Lucia: 香椿饼哎
Lucia: Chinese toon pancake, eh.
Jake: 香椿饼哎
Jake: Chinese toon pancake, eh.
Lucia: 可以我喜欢香椿
Lucia: Sure, I like Chinese toon.
Jake:今天就是要吃这个东西
Jake: Today we are eating this stuff.
Alice: 今天是谷雨
Alice: Today is Guyu (Grain Rain).
Alice: 所以要吃香椿椿菜
Alice: So we should eat Chinese toon dishes.
Alice: 是的
Alice: Yes.
Jake: 这就是莫名其妙的多了一个环节
Jake: This just randomly became another segment.
Jake: 我也不知道
Jake: I don't even know.
Alice:是谁这么有生活品味
Alice: Who has such a taste for life?
Lucia: 生活总是充满了变化
Lucia: Life is always full of changes.
Alice: 是今天确实应该吃香椿
Alice: Yes, today we really should eat Chinese toon.
Tasha: 香椿是什么
Tasha: What's Chinese toon?
Alice: 香椿是一种
Alice: Chinese toon is a kind of...
Jake: 你肯定知道因为我们加了一个荠菜
Jake: You must know because we added some shepherd's purse.
Lucia: 荠菜
Lucia: Shepherd's purse.
Tasha: 荠菜是荠菜吗
Tasha: Shepherd's purse is shepherd's purse?
Alice: 不是荠菜
Alice: It's not shepherd's purse.
Jake: 荠就差不多的东西吧
Jake: It's almost the same thing, right?
Jake: 我也说不上
Jake: I can't really say.
Alice: 荠菜是地上挖的
Alice: Shepherd's purse is dug from the ground.
Alice: 香椿树上长的
Alice: Chinese toon grows on trees.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 我分不清这野菜
Alice: I can't tell these wild veggies apart.
Jake: 大白菜
Jake: Napa cabbage.
Lucia: 这个小架子好好看
Lucia: This little rack looks so nice.
Jake: 感觉是文件
Jake: Feels like it's for documents.
Lucia: 可以用来放
Lucia: Can use it to put...
Jake: 放文件呢
Jake: Put documents, yeah.
Jake: 放笔筒笔筒
Jake: Put pen holders, pen holders.
Jake: 放文件袋
Jake: Put document bags.
Lucia: 我刚也想说
Lucia: I was about to say that too.
Jake: 文件夹
Jake: File folders.
Tasha: 做完我就带回去放文件夹哈哈哈
Tasha: After I finish it, I'll take it back to put file folders, hahaha.
Lucia: 我可以申请瓜分一个吗
Lucia: Can I apply to split one?
Lucia: 带回去放笔筒
Lucia: Take it back to put pen holders.
Tasha: 你想要瓜分哪个
Tasha: Which one do you want to split?
Lucia: 可能这个吧
Lucia: Maybe this one.
Jake:是什么书架
Jake: What kind of bookshelf is it?
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 对底下可
Lucia: Yes, the bottom part can...
Jake: 对这能放记事本
Jake: Yeah, you can put a notebook here.
Lucia: 底下可以放点小东西
Lucia: The bottom part can hold some small items.
Lucia: 对然后上面
Lucia: Yes, and then the top...
Lucia: 上面可以放我买那个小夜灯
Lucia: The top can hold that little nightlight I bought.
Lucia: 我打算把那个夜灯给他带回家去
Lucia: I'm planning to take the nightlight home for him.
Tasha: 这个怎么弄啊
Tasha: How do you do this?
Jake: 这是啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Ah
Alice: 应该有螺丝可以把那个钉拧上去哦
Alice: There should be screws to tighten it up.
Lucia: 他对他应该有把手哦
Lucia: Yeah, there should be handles for it.
Jake: 哎哦这个确实哦
Jake: Ah, right, that's true.
Lucia: 您那个您那个
Lucia: Your, your...
Lucia: 那个小螺丝刀可以派上用场了
Lucia: That small screwdriver will come in handy.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 没事杨老板好多螺丝刀
Lucia: No worries, Jake has lots of screwdrivers.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 放这吧就一个
Jake: Just put it here, just one.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊啊啊
Jake: Hahaha, ahhh.
Lucia: 啊哈哈啊啊
Lucia: Ahaha, ahhh.
Tasha: 不是还有一个吗
Tasha: Isn't there another one?
Jake: 这里面还有两个好像
Jake: There are two more inside, I think.
Jake: 希望没有
Jake: Hopefully not.
Alice: 这还有一个够了吗
Alice: There's still one here, is it enough?
Jake: 不够
Jake: Not enough.
Jake: 四个
Jake: Four.
Tasha: 这不是三个吗
Tasha: Isn't this three?
Tasha: 这上面还有一个
Tasha: There's another one up here.
Jake: 对不起
Jake: Sorry.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 这个是
Lucia: This is...
Lucia: 这就是单独的吗
Lucia: Is this separate?
Tasha: 嗯好像是
Tasha: Hmm, seems like it.
Tasha: 我也不知道
Tasha: I don't know either.
Jake: 今天晒不了太阳
Jake: We can't get any sun today.
Jake: 有点亏亏的
Jake: A bit of a loss.
Lucia: 走走走走走
Lucia: Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Lucia: 我们手拉小手
Lucia: Let's hold hands.
Lucia: 今天可以去春游
Lucia: We can go on a spring outing today.
Tasha: 他们说今天不春游
Tasha: They said no spring outing today.
Alice: 今天应该就在家里蹲
Alice: We should just stay at home today.
Lucia: 今天的节气
Lucia: Today's solar term.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 不一定非要春游
Lucia: We don't necessarily have to go on a spring outing.
Alice: 这咋啦烫的还是
Alice: What's up, is it burnt?
Tasha: 烫的吧应该
Tasha: I think it's burnt.
Tasha: 以前烫的对
Tasha: It was burnt before, right.
Tasha: 已经不记得了
Tasha: I can't remember anymore.
Lucia: 哎你画了一个项链
Lucia: Oh, you drew a necklace.
Alice: 是的跟他的衣服配套的
Alice: Yes, it matches his clothes.
Alice: 嗯超可爱的
Alice: Hmm, super cute.
Alice: 小心思小妙小妙思
Alice: Such little thoughtful details.
Lucia: 好多巴胺女孩哈
Lucia: So many dopamine girls, huh.
Tasha: 是这样的
Tasha: That's right.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice: 明显吗
Alice: Is it obvious?
Alice: 哦我还以为是那个头发
Alice: Oh, I thought it was the hair.
Tasha: 我还以为是内衣带
Tasha: I thought it was the underwear strap.
Tasha: 太明显了
Tasha: Too obvious.
Alice: 这有什么的没事
Alice: It's no big deal.
Alice: 坐下吹会风吗
Alice: Want to sit down and enjoy the breeze?
Alice: 饿吗
Alice: Hungry?
Tasha: 现在好像还不太饿
Tasha: Not really hungry yet.
Tasha: 咕咕咕
Tasha: Gurgle gurgle
Jake: 这是我22年年底在
Jake: This was me at the end of 2022.
Tasha: 小米是吗
Tasha: Xiaomi, right?
Lucia: 小米年这是你那个超高级的曲子吗
Lucia: Xiaomi year, is this your super advanced tune?
Jake: 就就是
Jake: Yeah, that's it.
Tasha: 小米也有
Tasha: Xiaomi also has it.
Jake: 嗯挺多的这种
Jake: Yeah, quite a lot of those.
Jake: 嗯那年隔离回国
Jake: That year, I quarantined when I came back to the country.
Jake: 隔离在酒店
Jake: Quarantined in a hotel.
Tasha: 这是干嘛的
Tasha: What's this for?
Tasha: 这是不同的头吗
Tasha: Different heads?
Jake: 对拆电脑的
Jake: Yeah, for disassembling the computer.
Jake: 当时把我麦克给拆了
Jake: I took apart my mic back then.
Jake: 然后拆了没装回去
Jake: Then I didn't put it back together.
Jake: 哈哈哈最后变成个台式机
Jake: Hahaha, it ended up becoming a desktop.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 啊哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha
Jake: 惊慌散了
Jake: The panic is gone.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Jake: 你知道散装了
Jake: You know it's scattered.
Lucia: 哦行吧
Lucia: Oh, fine.
Lucia: 散装但依然能用
Lucia: It's scattered but still usable.
Jake: 散装能用
Jake: Scattered but usable.
Lucia: 哇这
Lucia: Wow this
Lucia: 这怎么不算一种赛博朋克呢
Lucia: How is this not considered cyberpunk?
Lucia: 行吧还是您比较厉害
Lucia: Okay, you're still more impressive.
Alice: 这个就是不同的头都有
Alice: This one has different heads.
Lucia: 我修我修过
Lucia: I fixed, I fixed it before.
Lucia: 我修电脑
Lucia: I repaired computers.
Lucia: 干过最大的工程
Lucia: The biggest project I did
Lucia: 就是给自己加装内存条
Lucia: was installing RAM for myself.
Lucia: 剩下我啥都不敢干
Lucia: I wouldn't dare do anything else.
Lucia: 因为我要是拆了我就装回去了
Lucia: Because if I took it apart, I could put it back.
Jake: 当时为了换了几个键盘键
Jake: At that time, to replace a few keyboard keys
Jake: 然后把整个MAC给拆了
Jake: I took apart the whole MAC.
Lucia: 但是您把它拆了还能组装成台式机
Lucia: But you dismantled it and reassembled it into a desktop.
Lucia: 这我真没想到
Lucia: I really didn't expect that.
Lucia: 怎么凭空还多了一些零件呢
Lucia: How did extra parts appear out of nowhere?
Lucia: 哈哈没有
Lucia: Haha, no.
Jake: 没有就是屏幕散开
Jake: No, it's just the screen came apart.
Lucia: 装回去发现零件多了
Lucia: When putting it back, I found extra parts.
Lucia: 装哈哈
Lucia: Haha, assembling it.
Alice: 这确实香椿饼是你点的吗
Alice: Was this Toona sinensis pancake ordered by you?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Jake: 呃算是呃
Jake: Uh, sort of, uh
Jake: 百度文信一年都没开
Jake: I haven't opened Baidu Wenxin for a year.
Shure:  他问百度的
Shure: He asked Baidu.
Jake: 对只能问百度
Jake: Yes, we can only ask Baidu.
Shure:  这谷雨要吃啥
Shure: What do you eat for Grain Rain?
Tasha: 香椿饼啊
Tasha: Toona sinensis pancake.
Jake: 对他没说饺子
Jake: Yes, he didn't mention dumplings.
Jake: 但是我们还是点
Jake: But we still order.
Shure:  因为饺子总不会错的
Shure: Because you can never go wrong with dumplings.
Shure:  毕竟好吃不过饺子
Shure: After all, nothing beats dumplings.
Jake:这个对
Jake: That's right.
Alice: 我还以为香椿饼是专门点的
Alice: I thought the Chinese toon pancake was specially ordered.
Jake: 就是是是专门点的就是
Jake: Yes, yes, it was specially ordered.
Shure:  为了今天这个节气
Shure: For today's solar term.
Jake: 对问了百度说今儿应该吃点啥
Jake: Yeah, I asked Baidu what we should eat today.
Jake: 今天还有叫逛谷雨还是走
Jake: There's also something called "Gu Yu Walk" today.
Jake: 谷雨什么呀
Jake: Gu Yu what?
Jake: 走谷雨
Jake: "Gu Yu Walk."
Shure:  就是拿着篮子出去溜达一圈
Shure: It's like taking a basket and going for a stroll.
Tasha: 那我要拿那个
Tasha: Then I want to take that.
Lucia: 那那我们去撸狗吧
Lucia: Then let's go walk the dog.
Shure:  对我们就拿着个
Shure: Yeah, we just take it.
Jake: 对对对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 是啥呀
Jake: What is it?
Shure:  然后唱着采蘑菇的小姑娘哈哈
Shure: And then sing the song "Little Girl Picking Mushrooms," haha.
Lucia: 我特别喜欢这个颜色就是
Lucia: I really like this color, it's just...
Lucia: 感觉很好看
Lucia: It looks really nice.
Jake: 我要把它给先拿出来
Jake: I'm going to take it out first.
Tasha: 这写的什么乱七八糟的
Tasha: What kind of messy writing is this?
Lucia: 西拉v这个
Lucia: Syrah, V, this one.
Tasha: 是吗这什么语
Tasha: Really, what language is this?
Lucia: 法语哦
Lucia: It's French.
Tasha: 对不起
Tasha: Sorry.
Lucia: 但这个c这是不是写错了
Lucia: But this "c" here, is it a mistake?
Lucia: 应该是CEST
Lucia: It should be "CEST."
Lucia: 是哪个我法语不好
Lucia: Which one? My French is not good.
Jake:法律知道生活
Jake: "Law knows life."
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 希腊v就是这
Lucia: "Syrah V," this one.
Lucia: 好像是这就是生活
Lucia: Seems like "This is life."
Lucia: 有没有Nana pa得
Lucia: Is there a "Nana pa de"?
Lucia: please
Lucia: Please.
Lucia: new是我们
Lucia: "New" is our...
Lucia: 我们的主格
Lucia: Our subject pronoun.
Lucia: to ru不认识
Lucia: "To ru," I don't know.
Lucia: 如果只有一个ru的话就是
Lucia: If it's just "ru," it means...
Lucia: 就是白天或者今天的意思
Lucia: It means daytime or today.
Lucia: commasico
Lucia: "Commasico."
Alice: 法语是表音的文字吗
Alice: Is French a phonetic language?
Lucia: 是啊
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 呃不是吗
Lucia: Uh, isn't it?
Lucia: 不是你是圆学的
Lucia: No, you learned this from Yuan.
Alice: 不是不是我不是我
Alice: No, no, it wasn't me.
Alice: 我没我不知道啊
Alice: I didn't, I don't know.
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: Maybe.
Lucia: 像他们这些拉丁语系的
Lucia: Like those Latin languages.
Lucia: 应该都是表音的
Lucia: They should all be phonetic.
Lucia: 看不太懂
Lucia: I can't really understand.
Jake: 应该都就中文
Jake: It should all be in Chinese.
Jake: 还有谁
Jake: Who else?
Lucia: 不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 这东亚地区的这些语言
Lucia: The languages in East Asia.
Tasha: 另一个那个呢
Tasha: What about the other one?
Tasha: 螺丝呢
Tasha: What about the screws?
Jake: 没了在这呢听见一抹的小日本歌
Jake: There's no more, here, listen to a bit of Japanese music.
Tasha: 这人也太抠了
Tasha: This person is too stingy.
Tasha: 就发4螺丝
Tasha: Only gave 4 screws.
Tasha: 要是丢了怎么办
Tasha: What if they get lost?
Jake: 给我粘上
Jake: Stick them on for me.
Jake: 我们有很多双双面胶
Jake: We have lots of double-sided tape.
Jake: 摄像头的双面胶
Jake: Double-sided tape for the cameras.
Lucia: 很猛啊
Lucia: Very impressive.
Lucia: 你看我罗翔的那个刑法视频没
Lucia: Did you watch Luo Xiang's criminal law video?
Lucia: 警察局局长从旁边过说好猛啊
Lucia: The police chief walked by and said "very impressive."
Tasha: 是这个哦
Tasha: Is it this one?
Lucia: 是吗哈哈哈草
Lucia: Really? Hahaha, wow.
Lucia: 看不懂看不懂看不懂
Lucia: I don't understand, I don't understand, I don't understand.
Lucia: 我法语基本上是看剧学的
Lucia: I basically learned French from watching shows.
Lucia: 所以就是一旦不是台词我就看不懂
Lucia: So if it's not lines, I don't understand.
Jake: 要不翻译一下就是
Jake: How about translating it?
Lucia: 啊我的
Lucia: Oh my...
Lucia: 但谷歌翻译在国内连不上啊
Lucia: But Google Translate doesn't work in China.
Lucia: 我现在有那个啥对
Lucia: Now I have something, right.
Jake: 你现在有了
Jake: Now you have it.
Jake: 现在不是
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake: 就在这个墙外墙外墙内不是一个体系
Jake: Being inside and outside the firewall is different.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 这个比较容易看懂
Lucia: This is easier to understand.
Lucia: 但我觉得
Lucia: But I think...
Lucia: 咖啡和巴西的拼写是不是不太对啊
Lucia: The spelling of coffee and Brazil isn't quite right, is it?
Lucia: 100%阿拉比卡咖啡啊啊
Lucia: 100% Arabica coffee, ahh
Tasha: 哪里有咖啡
Tasha: Where’s the coffee?
Tasha: 我是说盒子上应该印
Tasha: I mean, it should be printed on the box.
Lucia: 没事我们可以假装咖啡豆
Lucia: No worries, we can pretend they're coffee beans.
Jake: 咖啡豆是吧
Jake: Coffee beans, right?
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Jake: 这个是英语
Jake: This is in English.
Jake: 纯英语这个是什么
Jake: Pure English, what’s this?
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Jake: 这是哪
Jake: Where is this?
Jake: 国语西语
Jake: Mandarin or Spanish.
Lucia: 不是吧
Lucia: I don’t think so.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don’t know.
Tasha: 你说这盒子里能放什么好吃的呢
Tasha: What tasty things can you put in this box?
Tasha: 这不是开玩笑嘛
Tasha: Isn’t this a joke?
Jake: 这个还得晒晒对吧
Jake: This needs some sun, right?
Jake: 吹一吹吧
Jake: Let’s blow on it.
Tasha: 我就把这两盒子拿走
Tasha: I’ll just take these two boxes.
Tasha: 这样子放还比较好放
Tasha: They’re easier to place like this.
Jake: 那我刚刚干嘛了
Jake: What was I doing just now?
Jake: 也行吧
Jake: That works too.
Lucia: 这个可以放在旁边当装饰啊
Lucia: This can be used as decoration on the side.
Tasha: 这个可以单独的
Tasha: This can be separate.
Tasha: 这样子啊
Tasha: Like this.
Jake: 对对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 看来我们东西有很多啊
Jake: Looks like we have a lot of stuff.
Jake: 很多很多
Jake: A lot, a lot.
Alice: 这个适合放口红
Alice: This is good for lipsticks.
Alice: 还带分装格
Alice: It even has compartments.
Lucia: 嗯这个放进去可以放那个什么
Lucia: Yeah, you can put, like, earrings and small jewelry in here.
Lucia: 放什么耳环耳钉这种小首饰好
Lucia: It’s good for earrings and studs.
Tasha: 好好太好了
Tasha: Great, that’s awesome.
Lucia: 是吧特别棒
Lucia: Right, it’s amazing.
Lucia: 首饰盒放桌子上还不占地方
Lucia: The jewelry box doesn’t take up much space on the table.
Tasha: 扇一扇
Tasha: Fan it.
Lucia: 我们已经给他想好就是以后的功能了
Lucia: We’ve already figured out what its future use will be.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 装可爱
Tasha: Acting cute.
Lucia: 这个呢
Lucia: How about this?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈装可爱
Lucia: Haha, acting cute.
Jake: 这怎么装可爱
Jake: How is this cute?
Jake: 这什么玩意
Jake: What is this thing?
Lucia: 他比较可
Lucia: It's kinda cute.
Jake: 小房子是吧
Jake: A little house, right?
Lucia: 他是个小房子
Lucia: It's a little house.
Tasha: 像那种爆钟的那个啊
Tasha: Like one of those exploding clocks.
Lucia: 哦对是的
Lucia: Oh yeah, it is.
Alice: 他可以勾住勾住好像
Alice: It can hook, like hook on.
Lucia: 给里面放一个
Lucia: Put one inside.
Lucia: 放一个圆的
Lucia: Put a round one inside.
Lucia: 那个啥圆的时钟
Lucia: Like a round clock.
Lucia: 嗯然后在上面再放一个小鸟
Lucia: Yeah, and then put a little bird on top.
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Sounds good.
Lucia: 好这个的日后归宿也想好了
Lucia: Okay, we've figured out its future.
Lucia: 那俩盘不用给他想什么了
Lucia: No need to think too much about those two plates.
Lucia: 因为都挺都很常见很好用
Lucia: They're common and useful.
Alice: 这个是不是也能可以养小蜘蛛
Alice: Can this also house little spiders?
Alice: 一人一个隔间
Alice: Each in a separate compartment.
Lucia: 太小了
Lucia: Too small.
Lucia: 这个可以养
Lucia: You can keep some.
Lucia: 对狼蛛会爬出来
Lucia: But the tarantulas might crawl out.
Alice: 就是我想养蛇
Alice: I want to keep a snake.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I also want a snake.
Alice: 喜欢养栖动物
Alice: I love keeping reptiles.
Lucia: 对我也想养蛇
Lucia: Yeah, I want a snake too.
Tasha: 但是我之前我还有一个学长
Tasha: But I had a senior before.
Tasha: 他在养那个什么守宫守宫啊蜥蜴守宫啊
Tasha: He kept geckos and lizards.
Lucia: 蜥蜴那种
Lucia: Lizards, those kind.
Tasha: 然后每天他的手上就爬着一条蛇
Tasha: And every day, a snake would crawl on his hand.
Tasha: 然后肩上还趴着一条
Tasha: And another one perched on his shoulder.
Tasha: 有点吓人
Tasha: A bit scary.
Lucia: 我也想养蛇
Lucia: I also want a snake.
Jake: 狼珠多大呀
Jake: How big can a tarantula get?
Lucia: 就看你买的多大
Lucia: Depends on what you buy.
Lucia: 也可以你也可以从这么小开始养
Lucia: You can start with a small one.
Lucia: 你也可以直接买一个拳头大的
Lucia: Or directly get one as big as a fist.
Lucia: 对它会蜕皮
Lucia: It'll shed its skin.
Lucia: 然后慢慢变得很大
Lucia: And slowly grow bigger.
Jake: 它最大能到哪
Jake: What's the biggest it can get?
Lucia: 最大
Lucia: The biggest.
Lucia: 一般可能最大也就拳头那么大吧
Lucia: Usually, the biggest is about the size of a fist.
Lucia: 我感觉
Lucia: I feel like...
Lucia: 你也可以直接买拳头那么大的
Lucia: You could just buy one that's the size of a fist.
Lucia: 因为从这么小开始养
Lucia: Because raising it from this small...
Lucia: 很容易中间把它养死
Lucia: It’s easy to accidentally kill it.
Jake: 他营养不够高血
Jake: It doesn’t have enough nutrition.
Lucia: 呃呃不知道为啥
Lucia: Uh, I don't know why.
Lucia: 就是不知道为啥
Lucia: Just don’t know why.
Jake: 好吧不知道要养几年
Jake: Well, I wonder how many years it takes to raise it.
Jake: 这个他能活多久
Jake: How long can it live?
Lucia: 能活多久
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 我也不知道
Lucia: I don’t know either.
Lucia: 我经常把动物养死
Lucia: I often end up killing the animals I raise.
Tasha: 这是干嘛的
Tasha: What’s this for?
Jake: 真不知道
Jake: No idea.
Lucia: 能活能活多久呀
Lucia: How long can it live?
Lucia: 两三年应该不清楚
Lucia: Probably two or three years, not sure.
Alice: 想养蛇
Alice: I want to raise a snake.
Lucia: 我也想要蛇
Lucia: I want a snake too.
Lucia: 但是蛇要吃老鼠崽子
Lucia: But snakes need to eat baby mice.
Lucia: 对然后那个东西要放冰箱里冷藏
Lucia: And those need to be stored in the fridge.
Lucia: 我不是很能接受
Lucia: I can’t really handle that.
Lucia: 他跟我冰箱
Lucia: Sharing a fridge with that...
Lucia: 他跟我共用一个冰箱放吃的
Lucia: Sharing a fridge with my food.
Alice: 你可以专门给他买个冰箱
Alice: You could buy a separate fridge just for it.
Jake: 买什么老鼠崽子
Jake: Buy what, baby mice?
Lucia: 舍不得
Lucia: Too expensive.
Lucia: 太贵了比蛇都贵
Lucia: More expensive than the snake itself.
Jake: 老鼠崽子是什么
Jake: What are baby mice?
Lucia: 这老鼠崽子
Lucia: Baby mice...
Lucia: 那刚出生的老鼠崽子
Lucia: Newborn baby mice.
Jake: 哦然后为什么冻起来
Jake: Oh, why freeze them?
Lucia: 因为要给蛇吃
Lucia: Because they’re for the snake to eat.
Lucia: 就是你不能让它吃的
Lucia: You can't let it eat...
Lucia: 给它毒死了吧
Lucia: Poisoned ones, right?
Jake: 他他是活的吗
Jake: Are they alive?
Lucia: 不是就是应该是新鲜的死老鼠
Lucia: No, they’re supposed to be fresh dead mice.
Jake: 新鲜的死老鼠为什么会死的
Jake: Why are fresh dead mice dead?
Lucia: 刚死的老鼠
Lucia: Just recently dead mice.
Jake: 为什么能不能
Jake: Why, can't we...
Jake: 能不能养点活的
Jake: Can't we raise some live ones?
Lucia: 我以后养活老鼠
Lucia: I'll raise live mice in the future.
Tasha: 哈哈就在大城市卖老鼠然后卖
Tasha: Haha, then sell mice in the big city, then sell...
Jake: 刚死的活老鼠
Jake: Recently dead live mice?
Lucia: 它一般
Lucia: They generally...
Lucia: 就是就是那种爬宠店
Lucia: It's like those reptile pet shops.
Lucia: 就会有卖各种各样吃的
Lucia: They sell all sorts of food.
Lucia: 狼蛛吃的也很那个啥
Lucia: Tarantulas also eat that stuff.
Lucia: 他吃不过那个有的鸟也吃
Lucia: But some birds eat it too.
Lucia: 就那种小虫子了
Lucia: Those little bugs.
Lucia: 所以那个还比较好搞一些
Lucia: So it's relatively easy to get.
Lucia: 面包虫就是很多鸟也吃那个
Lucia: Mealworms, a lot of birds eat them too.
Lucia: 如果养鸟的话
Lucia: If you're raising birds.
Jake: 我以为吃很多鸟
Jake: I thought you meant eating a lot of birds.
Lucia: 哈哈哈谁吃谁还不一定呢哈
Lucia: Hahaha, who eats who is not certain. Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice: 谁吃谁还不一定呢
Alice: Who eats who is not certain.
Alice: 哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 拳头这么大
Lucia: This big, like a fist.
Jake: 拳头这么大应该也能吃一只
Jake: This big, like a fist, it should be able to eat one too.
Lucia: 嗯但是
Lucia: Yeah, but...
Alice: 蜜袋雾也挺好挺可爱的
Alice: Sugar gliders are pretty cute too.
Alice: 但是他吃的那个东西我实在是受不了
Alice: But what they eat, I really can't stand.
Alice: 我我
Alice: I... I...
Lucia: 密带雾吃啥
Lucia: What do sugar gliders eat?
Jake: 那个那个是什么东西
Jake: What is that thing?
Lucia: 就是一种动物
Lucia: It's a kind of animal.
Alice: 大的那个
Alice: The big one...
Alice: 大蚕蛹不是大蚕蛹
Alice: The big silkworm pupa, not the big silkworm pupa.
Alice: 就是那种
Alice: It's like...
Alice: 说啥呢
Alice: What are you talking about?
Lucia: 哦是那种
Lucia: Oh, it's like...
Lucia: 就是就是那个炒的那个是吧
Lucia: It's like that fried one, right?
Lucia: 就是
Lucia: Like...
Lucia: 人好像也吃长得像蚕蛹的那个东西
Lucia: People also eat those, they look like silkworm pupae.
Alice: 你还得给他撕开
Alice: You even have to tear it open for them.
Jake: 嗯他吃
Jake: Hmm, they eat...
Jake: 中文吗
Jake: Chinese?
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 怎么写蜂蜜的
Jake: How do you write "honey"?
Alice: 蜜袋鼠的袋雾
Alice: Pouch of the sugar glider.
Alice: 就是那个
Alice: Like that.
Alice: 一个鼠一个无
Alice: One mouse and one "no".
Lucia: 他会飞啊
Lucia: It can fly!
Alice: 也不是会飞
Alice: Not really fly.
Lucia: 就是他会滑翔
Lucia: It can glide.
Alice: 对会滑翔
Alice: Yes, it can glide.
Lucia: 不是他是哺乳动物吧
Lucia: Isn't it a mammal?
Lucia: 是哺乳动物吧
Lucia: It's a mammal, right?
Alice: 老鼠吧
Alice: A mouse, right?
Lucia: 老鼠是那个什么啮齿类
Lucia: Mice are rodents.
Alice: 然后他的这个
Alice: And it has this...
Alice: 这个跟他的腿中间有那个翼
Alice: This wing-like thing between its legs.
Lucia: 还是什么什么动物
Lucia: Or some other kind of animal.
Alice: 然后就是可以从高处把它扔下来
Alice: You can throw it from a high place...
Alice: 他就像一个滑翔的效果
Alice: And it glides down.
Lucia: 就像翼装飞行一样那种
Lucia: Like wingsuit flying.
Alice: 对然后你就可以用比如说他从那里
Alice: Yeah, and then you can have it go from there...
Jake: 蝙蝠的亲戚
Jake: A relative of bats.
Alice:嗯可以这么理解
Alice: Yeah, you could say that.
Lucia: 是吗
Lucia: Really?
Lucia: 蝙蝠会飞啊
Lucia: Bats can fly.
Alice: 但是近亲吧
Alice: But they're closely related.
Lucia: 但是那个不会
Lucia: But that one can't.
Alice: 他的表哥表弟
Alice: Like its cousins.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Jake: 那他最像的
Jake: So, the most similar...
Jake: 我一般常见的动物是
Jake: The most common animal I know is...
Jake: 行好好好
Jake: Okay, alright.
Alice: 然后比如说从那里飞过来
Alice: So, for example, it can fly over from there...
Lucia: 神奇宝贝
Lucia: Like a Pokémon.
Alice: 哈哈哈从那里飞过来
Alice: Haha, flying over from there...
Alice: 然后你就接着他
Alice: And then you catch it.
Alice: 就他这种就特别粘人
Alice: It's very clingy.
Lucia: 如果你接着他
Lucia: If you catch it...
Alice: 如果你接不住他他不会摔死
Alice: If you don't catch it, it won't fall to its death.
Lucia: 哦真的吗
Lucia: Oh, really?
Lucia: 我喜欢粘人的动物
Lucia: I like clingy animals.
Alice: 但是他会被气死
Alice: But it might get angry.
Lucia: 被气死
Lucia: I'm so annoyed.
Alice: 就是你为什么接不住我呢
Alice: Why couldn't you catch me?
Alice: 他真的会
Alice: He really will.
Alice: 他会气死
Alice: He will get mad.
Jake: 生气会干嘛就不吃饭
Jake: What does he do when he's mad? Just skips meals?
Lucia: 嗯可能会不跟你玩会把自己气死
Lucia: Yeah, maybe he won't play with you and gets mad at himself.
Alice: 反正会被会把自己气死啊
Alice: Anyway, he will get mad at himself!
Jake: 就是不吃饭估计
Jake: Just skips meals, I guess.
Lucia: 啊好想养
Lucia: Ah, I really want to keep one.
Lucia: 我喜欢这种比较粘人的动物
Lucia: I like these clingy pets.
Lucia: 参与参与感
Lucia: They give a sense of participation.
Alice: 暹罗猫嘛
Alice: Siamese cats, right?
Alice: 暹罗猫像狗一样的
Alice: Siamese cats are like dogs.
Jake: 它认识你
Jake: They recognize you.
Jake: 会认识它认人
Jake: They recognize their owners.
Alice: 它很粘人的
Alice: They are very clingy.
Jake: 蜘蛛应该没这样吧
Jake: Spiders aren't like that, right?
Lucia: 嗯不是
Lucia: No, they aren't.
Lucia: 他总共那么大一点
Lucia: They're so small.
Lucia: 你指望他多大脑子呀
Lucia: How big a brain do you expect them to have?
Lucia: 蛇也不怎么认吧
Lucia: Snakes don't recognize people either, right?
Lucia: 蛇脑仁也很小
Lucia: Snakes have tiny brains too.
Alice:就很粘人
Alice: Just very clingy.
Alice:我就喜欢这种粘人
Alice: I just like clingy ones.
Lucia: 对我也是
Lucia: Yeah, me too.
Lucia: 但是但是我就是
Lucia: But, but I just...
Lucia: 我爸妈不喜欢把家里弄得很乱
Lucia: My parents don't like the house getting messy.
Lucia: 所以我就不能养这种猫啊狗啊的
Lucia: So I can't keep cats or dogs.
Lucia: 虽然我很想养
Lucia: Even though I really want to.
Lucia: 我可以去了解一下这个蜜袋鼯
Lucia: I can check out sugar gliders.
Lucia: 看能不能养一个
Lucia: See if I can keep one.
Lucia: 它大吗不大
Lucia: Are they big? No, right?
Alice: 不大不大
Alice: No, not big at all.
Alice:它就一个手就能拖着它
Alice: You can hold them in one hand.
Lucia: 哦哎
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 那还可以的
Lucia: Then that's fine.
Tasha: 你们在脑电波交流吗
Tasha: Are you guys communicating telepathically?
Jake: 没有我看他这个灯关了
Jake: No, I just saw his light was off.
Katrina:  是啊感觉提前过上了退休生活
Katrina: Yeah, feels like we're living a retired life early.
Lucia: 啊我灯还亮着吗
Lucia: Ah, is my light still on?
Lucia: 嗯那就行
Lucia: Hmm, that's fine.
Jake: 但他其实是这个头发挡住了
Jake: But actually, his hair was covering it.
Jake: 所以我刚刚让他撩一下
Jake: So I just asked him to move it aside.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 你应该这样
Lucia: You should do it like this.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Lucia: 就那天那个舞蹈里的动作哈哈
Lucia: Like that move in the dance the other day, haha.
Lucia: 我觉得我最好
Lucia: I think I am the best.
Alice: 所以昨天那个为什么
Alice: So why was it yesterday?
Alice: 那个什么161为什么代表3月21
Alice: Why does 161 represent March 21st?
Lucia: 不知道可能是g GPT在胡说
Lucia: No idea, maybe GPT was just making stuff up.
Tasha: 是不是没发昨天的功工资
Tasha: Wasn't yesterday's salary supposed to be paid?
Lucia: 好像是哦
Lucia: Seems like it.
Alice: 所以为什么
Alice: So why?
Alice: 为什么是321
Alice: Why is it 321?
Lucia: 他忘了他睡着了
Lucia: He forgot, he fell asleep.
Alice:161是吧对
Alice: It's 161, right.
Alice: 161为什么能代表3月21呢
Alice: Why does 161 represent March 21st?
Lucia: 不知道啊
Lucia: No idea.
Lucia: 我觉得GPT在胡说
Lucia: I think GPT was just making stuff up.
Lucia: 因为前一天的时候
Lucia: Because the day before
Lucia: 那个他不是也拆成两
Lucia: it also split it into two.
Lucia: 个吗然后靖康也是问的GPT
Lucia: And Jingkang also asked GPT.
Lucia: 里面有一个答案是说132是一个回文数
Lucia: One of the answers was that 132 is a palindrome.
Lucia: 但132明显不是一个回文数
Lucia: But 132 is obviously not a palindrome.
Lucia: 就正着和倒着是一样的
Lucia: It reads the same forward and backward.
Lucia: 就跟回文是一个意思对吧
Lucia: That's what a palindrome means, right?
Lucia: 132怎么能是回文数
Lucia: How can 132 be a palindrome?
Lucia: 我在群里问我说为什么132是回文数
Lucia: I asked in the group why 132 is a palindrome.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 然后他说不知道所以没有采纳
Lucia: And then he said he didn't know, so he didn't adopt it.
Lucia: 我说哦原来GPT4.0也胡说
Lucia: I said, oh, so GPT 4.0 also talks nonsense.
Alice: 植树节我还一开始我以为他弄错了
Alice: Arbor Day, at first I thought he got it wrong.
Alice: 他不是3月
Alice: Isn't it in March?
Lucia: 是3月 3月十几号好像
Lucia: It's in March, around the middle of March, I think.
Alice: 我我就记得我们不是312植树节吗
Alice: I remember it's on March 12th, Arbor Day, right?
Lucia: 是吗我不知道
Lucia: Is it? I don't know.
Lucia: 就是但确实是3月份
Lucia: But it is in March.
Alice: 是我记错了吗
Alice: Did I remember it wrong?
Lucia: 不我是我是不记得
Lucia: No, I don't remember.
Alice: 我是但是那个日子
Alice: I do, but the date...
Alice: 感觉就是跟我的印象好像
Alice: It doesn't seem right to me.
Alice: 不太对啊
Alice: Something feels off.
Alice: 然后我还去网上查了一下
Alice: So I looked it up online.
Alice: 原来每个国家的植树节都不是一样的
Alice: Turns out every country has a different Arbor Day.
Lucia: 哦原来是这样
Lucia: Oh, so that's how it is.
Lucia: 它不是个国际统一的节日
Lucia: It's not a globally unified holiday.
Jake: 多少克
Jake: How many grams?
Katrina:  就很忙啊
Katrina: Just very busy.
Lucia: 订单在京东北京天河散货分拣中心
Lucia: The order is at the JD Beijing Tianhe Sorting Center.
Lucia: 分拣完成
Lucia: Sorting completed.
Lucia: 我觉得今天应该能到一个
Lucia: I think it should arrive today.
Katrina:  学是学会了已经
Katrina: I've already learned it.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 别到时候我在淘宝上买那些小装饰
Lucia: Just don't let it happen that the decorations I bought from Taobao...
Lucia: 都没到然后那就会导致就是就是
Lucia: Don't arrive, and it causes...
Lucia: 我所有到的东西都是白色的
Lucia: Everything I have is white.
Alice: 没有一个是蓝色的
Alice: None of it is blue.
Lucia: 哈哈白色是
Lucia: Haha, white is...
Alice: 白色是
Alice: White is...
Alice: 是水还是金呢
Alice: Is it water or gold?
Lucia: 因为我想弄成那种蓝
Lucia: Because I want to make it blue...
Lucia: 就是以蓝白为主色调的
Lucia: Mainly blue and white.
Lucia: 所以我挑的都是一些蓝白的东西
Lucia: So I chose all blue and white stuff.
Lucia: 蓝白应该都属水吧
Lucia: Blue and white should both be water, right?
Alice: 蓝白应该都属水吧
Alice: Blue and white should both be water, right?
陌生人：简单打扫哎
Stranger: Just a simple clean-up.
Alice: 好的谢谢您
Alice: Okay, thank you.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Sure thing.
Alice: 啊阿姨
Alice: Ah, ma'am...
Alice: 那个底下那个黑色袋子里面是
Alice: The black bag down there...
Alice: 是那个玻璃碎渣
Alice: It's got glass shards.
Alice: 就就这个黑色袋子
Alice: This black bag here.
Lucia: 对对那个那个里面有
Lucia: Yes, yes, that one has them.
Lucia: 要小心一点这个
Lucia: Be careful with this.
Alice: 哎这里面是玻璃渣
Alice: Hey, there are glass shards in here.
Alice: 你小心
Alice: Be careful.
陌生人：我装这个袋子
Stranger: I'll use this bag.
陌生人：这个袋子厚一点
Stranger: This bag is thicker.
Lucia: 哎呦不好意思
Lucia: Oh, sorry!
Lucia: 哈哈没关
Lucia: Haha, no worries.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Lucia: 抱抱
Lucia: Hug!
Lucia: 你好纤细
Lucia: You're so slim!
Lucia: 嗯哈哈
Lucia: Mmm, haha.
Alice: 哈哈好纤细
Alice: Haha, so slim!
Lucia: 是吗可能是夏天手就能这
Lucia: Really? Maybe it's because it's summer.
Alice:样搂着你了
Alice: Yeah, hugging you feels like this.
Lucia: 夏天穿的少
Lucia: We wear less in summer.
Alice: 你不知道
Alice: You have no idea.
Alice: 我是不是Duang Duang的
Alice: Am I like "Duang Duang"?
Lucia: 没有呀
Lucia: No, not at all.
Lucia: 我觉得拥抱是一件很开心的事情
Lucia: I think hugging is a really happy thing.
Alice: 拥抱会分泌那什么
Alice: Hugging releases that...
Alice:忘了反正
Alice: I forgot, anyway...
Lucia: 多巴胺吗
Lucia: Dopamine?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 嗯多抱一会
Lucia: Mmm, let's hug a bit longer.
Lucia: 嘻嘻开心
Lucia: Hehe, happy.
Alice: 好像是催产素
Alice: I think it's oxytocin.
Alice: 如果没记错的话
Alice: If I remember correctly.
Lucia: 要不要进去看一看
Lucia: Want to go inside and take a look?
Lucia: 哎他们刚刚有找到剪刀吗
Lucia: Hey, did they find the scissors?
Lucia: 如果找到了的话我就可以
Lucia: If they did, I can...
Lucia: 我就可以把这个箱子给他砌了
Lucia: I can cut up this box for them.
陌生人：这箱子都要不要了吗
Stranger: Are you getting rid of this box?
Lucia: 呃有的不要了
Lucia: Uh, some of them, yes.
Lucia: 有的还有的可以留一下
Lucia: Some can still be kept.
Lucia: 行行
Lucia: Alright, alright.
Lucia: 咚咯咚
Lucia: Knock knock.
Katrina:  把它剪下来然后把它平开
Katrina: Cut it down and lay it flat.
Katrina:  然后这样放出去就行
Katrina: Then just put it out like this.
Lucia: 雨轩有找到剪刀吗
Lucia: Yuxuan, did you find the scissors?
Lucia: 哎找到了
Lucia: Oh, found them.
Katrina:  剪刀是那个冰箱里的
Katrina: The scissors were in the fridge.
Shure:  倒到大概用50克左右
Shure: Pour around 50 grams.
Katrina:  但这个好拆
Katrina: But this is easy to open.
Katrina:  快递吗
Katrina: Is it a delivery?
Lucia: 我也在想
Lucia: I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 这看起来就是剪花啊之类这些
Lucia: This looks like cutting flowers and stuff.
Alice: 来吧我来给你拆
Alice: Come on, let me open it for you.
Lucia: 柔软一点的比较好
Lucia: A softer one would be better.
Alice:我来给你拆
Alice: I'll open it for you.
Alice:你说你要哪个
Alice: Which one do you want?
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 拆快递
Lucia: Opening a package.
Lucia: 其实我用用我用这个东西拆也可以
Lucia: Actually, I could use this thing to open it too.
Lucia: 我是在想
Lucia: I was thinking...
Lucia: 如果我们要做一个纸箱狗的话
Lucia: If we want to make a cardboard dog...
Lucia: 就需要用剪刀把这个剪开
Lucia: We need to use scissors to cut this.
Lucia: 那对那个就要用那个
Lucia: For that, we need those...
Lucia: 就是全是铁的那种剪刀
Lucia: Completely metal scissors.
Lucia: 那个我怕就是给他别用
Lucia: I'm afraid if we use too much force, they'll break.
Lucia: 用劲太大剪劈了
Lucia: They'll cut too forcefully.
Katrina:  嗯哎
Katrina: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 现在戴着眼镜我可以拆这个快递了吧
Lucia: Now that I have my glasses on, I can open the package, right?
Lucia: 拆了管他呢
Lucia: Let's just open it.
Lucia: 反正没什么事干
Lucia: Anyway, there's nothing else to do.
Alice: 我找到了
Alice: I found it.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那个是用来压花的吗
Lucia: Is that for pressing flowers?
Lucia: 啊谢谢在哪里啊这是
Lucia: Ah, thanks. Where is this from?
Lucia: 可以可以有个剪刀
Lucia: Okay, okay, we've got scissors.
Lucia: 然后我们好像没有铅笔
Lucia: But it seems like we don't have a pencil.
Lucia: 但实在不行白板笔也行
Lucia: If it comes to it, a whiteboard marker will do.
Katrina:  我有那个黑纸
Katrina: I have some black paper.
Lucia: 呃那个碳碳素笔那种吗
Lucia: Uh, like a carbon pen or something?
Katrina:  就是普通的墨墨水笔啊
Katrina: Just a regular ink pen.
Lucia: 墨墨水笔啊
Lucia: An ink pen?
Lucia: 可以也可以
Lucia: That works too.
Lucia: 我觉得就是在纸板上画一下就
Lucia: I think just drawing on the cardboard would...
Katrina:  你要干什么就是
Katrina: What are you planning to do?
Lucia: 如果要那个什么的话
Lucia: If we want to...
Katrina:  我给你找找去
Katrina: I'll go find it for you.
Lucia: 没事没事不着急
Lucia: It's okay, no rush.
Lucia: 你可以先弄你的这个
Lucia: You can do your thing first.
Katrina:  你有想好要做什么样的小狗吗
Katrina: Have you decided what kind of dog you want to make?
Lucia: 没想好因为因为我不知
Lucia: I haven't decided yet because...
Lucia: 咱们是想要一个就是潦草一点的还是
Lucia: Are we going for something a bit rough or...
Alice: 是一人一只吗
Alice: Is it one per person?
Lucia: 可以一起做
Lucia: We can do it together.
Lucia: 反正我们好多箱子
Lucia: Anyway, we have lots of boxes.
Katrina:  就是这个活动啥的就是感觉压花什么都是随便你
Katrina: This activity, like pressing flowers, you can do whatever you want.
Katrina:  想玩就玩
Katrina: Play if you want.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Katrina:  我当时以为就是必须每个人想一个
Katrina: At first, I thought each person had to come up with something.
Katrina:  游戏就是每个人都要参与的
Katrina: Like everyone had to participate in the game.
Lucia: 对我也是
Lucia: Yeah, me too.
Alice: 那我要做一只发疯的小狗
Alice: Then I'll make a crazy little dog.
Katrina:  后来发现特别佛系
Katrina: Later, I realized it's super chill.
Lucia: 可以就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, totally.
Lucia: 其实那个狗很好做
Lucia: Actually, the dog is easy to make.
Lucia: 如果大家只是想潦草一点做的话
Lucia: If everyone just wants to do it casually.
Lucia: 就拿一个箱子
Lucia: Just take a box.
Lucia: 但是长宽比例要合适一点
Lucia: But make sure the proportions are right.
Lucia: 然后简单剪一下对就行了
Lucia: Then just cut it simply, and you're good.
Lucia: 简单剪一下然后给他
Lucia: Just cut it simply and then...
Lucia: 就你再拿另外一个那种就是瓦楞纸
Lucia: Take another piece of corrugated cardboard.
Lucia: 然后画一个小狗脑袋
Lucia: And draw a dog's head.
Lucia: 给他粘上就可以了
Lucia: Stick it on, and it's done.
Lucia: 对那个那种就很简单很简单
Lucia: Yeah, it's really simple.
Alice: 你的比例失调也没关系啊
Alice: Even if the proportions are off, it's fine.
Alice: 就有那种特别细长的那种细狗
Alice: There are those really long and thin dogs.
Lucia: 对对是的
Lucia: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 西狗就是
Lucia: Those dogs fit the scrappy look better.
Lucia: 就更加符合潦草小狗的形象
Lucia: They fit the image of a scrappy little dog.
Lucia: 这个是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is this?
Lucia: 我觉得这好像这是一
Lucia: I think this is...
Alice: 一会我要上厕所
Alice: I need to go to the bathroom later.
Lucia: 我觉得可以剥吗
Lucia: Do you think we can peel this?
Alice:这能播吗
Alice: Can we broadcast this?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice: 能录吗不能录
Alice: Can we record this? No, we can't.
Lucia: 你可以先放桌子上然后出出来了再带
Lucia: You can put it on the table first, then bring it out later.
Lucia: 应该没事了
Lucia: It should be fine.
Lucia: 这个是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is this?
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 这个也是昨天到的
Lucia: This also arrived yesterday.
Lucia: 有谁的快有谁的
Lucia: Whose is it? Whose?
Lucia: 京东快递是昨天到的吗
Lucia: Did the JD Express package arrive yesterday?
Katrina:  没有我没买京东
Katrina: No, I didn't buy from JD.
Katrina:  我都是淘宝
Katrina: I always shop on Taobao.
Lucia: 嗯但不知道
Lucia: Hmm, but I don't know.
Katrina:  这什么东西啊
Katrina: What's this thing?
Lucia: 因为这上面没写名字
Lucia: Because there's no name on it.
Katrina:  易碎物品
Katrina: Fragile item.
Lucia: 然后我觉得我觉得应该也不是我的
Lucia: And I think, I think it shouldn't be mine either.
Lucia: 因为我昨天应该就到了俩
Lucia: Because I should've received only two things yesterday.
Katrina:  杨杨这个笑脸
Katrina: Yang Yang, this smiley face.
Katrina:  这谁写的
Katrina: Who wrote this?
Katrina:  应该我写的
Katrina: Should be me.
Katrina:  杨靖康
Katrina: Yang Jingkang.